hi this is Ted Ballarat reason TV today
I'm at the Petersen Automotive Museum in
Los Angeles California and I'll be
sitting down with political satirist and
author PJ O'Rourke his latest book is
driving like crazy 30 years of vehicular
hell bending stick around and here
O'Rourke's take on bailouts easy women
and who ruined the US auto industry the
automobile although it's seen as you
know the source of all this bad stuff it
does produce a lot of wealth for a lot
of people the automobile is the source
of no bad stuff in America there
wouldn't be in America without an
automobile we are a huge country and we
you know the this country just didn't
come together as a nation until the car
was invented because of basically
transport problems we would be kind of
would be Australia if it weren't for the
car you know no offense to Australia
it's a nice enough country but it's too
many too few people in too huge is space
it just never came together as a real
nation you talk a lot about the American
love affair with the automobile do you
think that's been replaced with a love
affair with trains in the form of rail
transit light rail yes there's something
romantic about the Train but like but
try getting the tracks to come to your
house I mean when it comes time to
unload the groceries the romance with
the train disappears immediately
well maybe it's more than the
politicians love affair with politicians
love why do politicians love trains
because they can tell where the tracks
go they know where everybody's going I
mean politicians it's all about control
it is all about power politics itself is
nothing but an attempt to achieve power
and prestige without merit that is the
definition of politics politicians hate
cars they've always hated cars because
cars are make people free not only free
in the sense that they can go anywhere
they want which is bugs politicians in
the first place but they can move out of
the political district that the
politician represents so if it is mostly
the politicians who are in love with the
trains in that vein I want to show you a
little something from a book called
transport of delight by Jonathan
Richmond this goes back to you
1991 when here in Los Angeles they open
their very first rail transit line the
blue line and they decided to open it on
Valentine's Day because of course you
know again and I just want you to take a
look at how it was announced a tunnel
just waiting for a train a heart-shaped
ah a tunnel just calling dr. Freud does
it bother you when you hear new
Urbanists and others talking it's a it's
a favorite refrain of journalists that
were addicted to our automobiles
I just didn't bother me I want to
strangle them it's a little bit beyond
bother you know I want to stuff them in
their Prius and lock the doors is what I
want to do you know they just don't know
what they're talking about Americans
were able to create the life that we
have in America by being able to get out
of the big cities it was the corruption
of the urban political machines lousy
public schools insane municipal
bureaucracies the reason we live in the
suburbs is because we were able to
escape those things and the reason we
were able to escape those things
it wasn't the Train it was the car that
allowed us to get far enough away from
that stuff to build a decent life and
now with fast forward to GM and so many
people call it a government motors these
days and the typical scattershot way of
government we're hearing about all their
new goals cleaner greener somewhere on
the list is making cars that people want
to buy somewhere way down on the list
because if you want to see a
government-owned automobile go get an
East German Trabant that's the kind of
cars the government makes it's gonna be
garbage and of course it's garbage from
a number of points of view the the the
success of capitalism has everything to
do with
I mean people talk about the wealth that
capitalism creates but the poverty that
capitalism creates in capitalists not in
poor people is is also extremely
important when a business fails it's
time for a bit there's a reason for the
business fail they're making a product
nobody wants to buy you don't come in
there and save that product Obama
administration has got this economic
thing which is if it's if it's work and
tax the hell out of it if it's not work
and bail it out and if it's just
scraping by drop Barney Frank on it till
it screams for help now this isn't an
insane approach so there's been a lot of
Monday morning quarterbacking about what
went wrong with the US auto industry
what in your estimation went wrong well
I think several things happened one was
government regulation the government
regulation in particularly in the post
1973 after the first Arab oil embargo
the imposition on automobiles of cafe a
standards of fuel standards of emissions
standards of endless safety standards
all these things were very bad for the
car they made the car more complex less
elegant uglier in the case of five mile
an hour bumpers this they worked on
spoiling the American love affair with
the car there's also a lot of mandated
technology involved here the government
wasn't satisfied and saying look you
know the cars are making the air dirty
can you guys make the cars cleaner they
wanted to tell them how to make the cars
cleaner well these people don't know it
but the politicians don't know anything
about engineering so the situation was
very much like okay dad burns dinner so
we get the dog to cook you know we find
the one person who knows you know the
creature who knows even less about the
subject and we put him in charge so
there was that problem and also there
was the problem of a volatility it takes
a long time to design and produce
four years five years to get an
automobile through from the from its
conception stage to it actually rolling
off the production line cars companies
have always faced the problem of
volatility of consumer demand after all
the great bulk of automotive American
automobile companies have failed and not
been bailed out where was the word still
here we're still here people still have
jobs where was that happened where was
the government with Studebaker where was
the government with Packard where were
they with Hudson where were they with
Nash you know where were they with
Crosley soon nevermind but anyway a lot
of car companies have failed over the
years due to one type of volatility
volatility of consumer demand very scary
but if you add to that volatility in
commodity prices see car companies for
most of the hundred years that cars have
been around have been able to to predict
with reasonable accuracy exception for
what World War two maybe what gasoline
was gonna cost and what the iron and
steel and stuff it goes into an
automobile starting with the 70s you get
into a period of volatility where car
companies are forced to design cars are
going to come out in five years not only
don't they know what the public is gonna
want in five years but they also don't
know what the stuff that the cars made
out it is going to cost if you add on to
that the Third Kind of volatility the
real crime of government intervention in
automobiles not any specific thing that
they ask for cleaner air is good using
less gas that's probably good even five
mile an hour bumpers and safety
standards all this is good but you
couldn't tell what the government was
going to ask for next so you get
regulatory volatility so all of a sudden
car companies are facing three kinds of
volatility instead of just one kind of
volatility from Chevy to four you see a
lot of conflating the purchase of an
American car with patriotism do you
think it's patriotic to buy an American
person on first place most of most
American cars aren't actually American
cars I mean the parts come from all over
the place it the car itself may have
been assembled in Canada or Mexico
there's no such thing as an American car
all cars are Internet
all cars now on the other hand the
Toyota you buy may be made in the United
States to Honda you buy definitely will
be made in the United States at BMW buy
will be made in the United States of
Volkswagens too so you don't know
whether you're buying American I just
buy a good car buy the car